notre second débat il est vous savez
qu'on le fait régulièrement un
volontairement décalée de l'actualité du
jour on prend du recul pour analyser un
phénomène venu des états unis qui semble
s'imposer en france le big quitou la
grande des missions où sont passés les
salariés ont fait la liste des secteurs
en tension pour commencer avec ce sujet
signé jonathan du priem crise de sens
reconversion voir démission le coc vide
semble avoir bousculé les aspirations
des français en matière de carrière est
de fait un pacte et leur vision du
travail
à tendance qui se croisent
job à temps une combine pour telle
journée est la deuxième et la prise de
conscience brutale métier utile est
essentielle
forcément les attendait le marché du
travail a été de fait modifié par la
crise sanitaire des secteurs entiers
peine à recruter alors que l'offre est
pléthorique
au premier trimestre 2009 de 1 million
de postes étaient à pourvoir dont la
moitié en cdi un chiffre en trompe
l'oeil dans le détail certaines branches
comme les services à la personne le
commerce et la vente mais encore
l'hôtellerie et la restauration où près
de 140 mille postes sont à pourvoir ont
été frappés de plein fouet par la crise
sanitaire des métiers aux conditions
difficiles peu rémunérateur et très peu
adaptable au télétravail il décourage
pas
forcément
d'autres donc au temps réel mais les
autres d'autant que ce sont
d'autres secteurs doivent s'attendre à
une très grande tension à venir
notamment les métiers de la santé selon
le ministère du travail trois millions
de personnes seront en perte d'autonomie
d'ici à 2030 et auront besoin d'être
prises en charge par des professionnels
de santé
où sont passés les salariés voilà la
question à laquelle on va répondre tout
de suite il dans ce débat avec malaisie
bigi bonjour bienvenue vous êtes
sociologue maîtresse de conférences
chercheur affilié au centre d'études de
l'emploi et du travail
stefan müller ce bonjour bienvenue vous
êtes économiste à l'université paris ii
panthéon assas chaque oeil allemand
benoît serre directeur des ressources
humaines de l'oréal france et vice
président délégué de l'association
nationale des drh ont on a également
avec nous en duplex jean claude lavorel
quel président du groupe lavorel hôtel
bonsoir et bienvenue à vous aussi et
matthieu croissandeau éditorialiste
politique évidemment est resté à mes
côtés de bill quidditch parler d'eux
de ce phénomène américain mais les
belges y est ce que la france vit aussi
une grande démission alors c'est
difficile à savoir on a des chiffres il
nous indique qu'on irait peut-être vers
ça mais bon ce serait à coup sûr mais
donc ces chiffres c'est la hausse
continue en fait des ruptures
conventionnelles et des démissions qui
sont mesurées par le ministère du
travail et puis on a aussi donc un autre
organisme le céreq qui me dit que 35%
des jeunes s'interrogent sur leur avenir
professionnel depuis la crise sanitaire
il ya un autre indicateur qu on pourrait
citer c'est celui des demandes de bilan
de compétences qui pourraient atteindre
100 mille donc à la fin de l'année
beaucoup plus que d'habitude ça alors le
la caisse des dépôts nous dit que c'est
beaucoup plus longue et de que
d'habitude mais on n'a pas trop de
l'antériorité sur les chiffres donc du
coup c'est difficile de dire vraiment
s'il ya une grosse évolution mais en
tout cas il ya des gens qui
s'interrogent sur les revenus
professionnels ça c'est sûr alors c'est
mémé chiffres il recoupe les vôtres ça
je pense qu on se rejoint 1 million 600
mille salariés en cdi qui ont donné leur
démission en 2021 ça c'est une source
insee + 26 % même un chiffre assez
frappant et puis il ya aussi ce sondage
opinionway ça rejoint ce que vous disiez
35 % des français ont envie de
démissionner 42 % chez les moins de 35
ans étude opinionway qui datent de du
mois de mai dernier est-ce que c'est
fanny bière si on prend un peu de recul
on voit quand même un phénomène en cours
est ce que c'est un phénomène inédit qui
frappe notre pays déjà oui la pénurie de
main d'oeuvre c'est relativement inédit
je vous rappelle qu'on a quand même vécu
des dessinée avec un taux de chômage
très élevé qu'aujourd'hui on a un taux
de chômage record parce que à 7,3 pour
cent de la population active on n'avait
pas connu ça depuis depuis la dernière
crise de 2008 ce qui laisse en fait ce
qui explique que les démissionnaires
en perspective
leur capacité à retrouver facilement un
emploi lorsque effectivement la
dynamique est enclenchée je rappelle que
la dernière avait quand même une
croissance on est en situation de
reprise on avait un pipe qui augmentait
à plus de 2 7 % donc ça ça un peu
galvaniser les troupes et le marché du
travail et ça a donné espoir aux
salariés ben d'améliorer ou leurs
conditions de travail ou leur salaire
oui mais alors même si on est à 7,3 pour
cent effectivement niveau record depuis
donc le 10 et 14 ans il ya encore de 2
millions et quelques chômeurs donc pour
moi c'est quelque chose c'est vraiment
basique la question mais que comment ça
s'explique comment les deux phénomènes
sais que tu vas y avoir encore deux
millions de chômeurs et qui en tentant
de gens qui sont en train de chercher un
nouveau job ou quoi oui en fait seront
voir qu'il ya une pénurie de main
d'oeuvre dans les secteurs d'après oco
vide ou en fait les gens se sont
retrouvés à pas avec un salaire trop
faible par rapport à des horaires
décalés on a vu par exemple pour toutes
ces perles comme une copine ce qu'on
appelait des emplois est essentielle 1
ces emplois est essentielle ce soit dans
la dans la santé mais aussi les
caissières maintenant la distribution
les bouchers des tout ce qu'on sait sur
le transport on a fait un sujet quelques
heures de car il manque 7 à 8000
chauffeur de cas à la rentrée là c'est
quand même assez de temps de pose en
fait pendant le confinement ses huit
semaines notamment en fait a en fait
redistribue les cartes parce que les
salariés se sont dit mais pourquoi moi
je dois à ce salaire là me sacrifier à
voir ce
avec des horaires à ce point-là
contraint donc à dents voilà on se
retrouve aujourd'hui avec une séance
situation de reprise parce que c'est
quand même le cas quand les
l'économie s'est ré ouvert lé des gens
se sont mis à consommer et on a vu un
boom dans la restauration notamment et
avec des salariés qui étaient plus
d'accords de revenir à des conditions
passée donc il ya une nécessité de yassa
fait une pression sur les salaires et
puis ça va même au delà de ça c'est que
maintenant les conditions de travail
doivent changer c'est à dire que le
salary impose en fait de nouvelles
règles on y reviendra est vraiment et
notamment sur les solutions les leviers
que qu'on peut collectivement ils mal
imaginé benoît serre est ce qu'on est on
reste dans le constat là dans une
période un peu de de transition
finalement où il ya pas mal de salariés
qui se cherche que je ce que je
comprends qu'ils n'étaient pas
satisfaits de leur situation et quand
n'ont pas encore trouvé une nouvelle est
ce que c'est ça l'ex montois tube
principal je suis pas si une explication
principale parce qu'on a tout ce qui a
été évoqué les moyens de reprise
économique les enrobés sont confrontés
au fait que tout à coup il ya plus de
chômage de masse on s'était habitué
après vous avez la question
effectivement ce que vous avez évoqué
c'est à dire que les gens évaluent
maintenant le champ de contraintes par
rapport à la rémunération ils ont fait
voler leurs critères en réalité et comme
vous avez un système où finalement on
trouve un emploi la crainte de ne pas le
trouver a affaibli donc les gens par
plus tranquillement en se disant tout ce
temps je veux retrouver assez vite et si
vraiment en cas d'urgence je sais que
j'en prends de rien avec des contraintes
mais pourquoi y'a encore des millions de
chômeurs alors mais parce que vous avez
des tas de métiers où les gens pour le
coup se disent à date ça ne vaut pas le
coup je vais pas gagner ce prix là pour
avoir des horaires décalés des horaires
des coupes et donc de toute façon j'ai
moins peur entre guillemets parce que si
jamais un moment je peux vraiment plus
vivre parce que j'ai plus bas sont sera
embauché tout de suite vous avez tout le
monde se regarde un peu où en quelque
sorte et puis après tout ça c'est des
choses qui sont très immédiates et puis
vous avez des conspirations il ya une
vraie attente quand je le vois en termes
d'attentes d'organisation du travail de
kaya évidemment le télétravail
évidemment de qualité de vie au travail
de sens des choses il ya une vraie
attente et une somme est une forme
d'impatience à ce que les entreprises
c'est difficile j'en témoigne tire les
conséquences de ce qu'ils ont vécu
pendant un an et demi ils ont découvert
qu'un nouveau modèle d'organisation ce
marché dans même et donc ils mettent
beaucoup beaucoup de pression sur les
entreprises et maintenant ils ont les
moyens de donner puisque on est en
acquitter pour le moment j'espère que ça
va durer le chômage de masse c'est un
phénomène qui a existé même en temps de
crise avec le américain résume avec les
3d au fond je pense moi de contrôler les
boulots dirty dahn geos edit vending
c'est un risque et ça ce qui est
dangereux et ce qui est ce soit dans des
conditions dégradantes ou ce qui demande
beaucoup souffrent des secteurs comme la
boucherie industrielle
il y avait des pénuries de main-d'oeuvre
personne ne voulait y aller d'une
certaine façon les travaux publics aussi
ce qui est de ce qui est nouveau à mon
sens c'est que ça touche aujourd'hui
beaucoup plus de secteurs parce que il
ya eu cette période du confinement ou
peut-être qu'on a comparé mais tout le
monde s'est aussi interrogé sur sa
propre existence d'une certaine façon et
d'une certaine façon sûre je me lève
dans le rôle sur le rôle qu'on remplit
en namibie du tout la ligne plus
personne d'aller bosser en disant mais
qu'est ce que je fais de ma vie à quoi
bon face à renvoyer chacun à des
questions existentielles quand même
pendant les deux premiers mois en tout
cas du premier confinement et c'est vrai
que cet aspect un peu automatique
mécanique de jeu rempli ma cage fait la
tâche qu'on le demande mais maintenant
suscite des interrogations alors la
conjoncture économique fait en plus on
peut comparer on peut se dire c'est vrai
mais je te pourquoi pas faire autre
chose après tout mais je pense qu'il ya
quand même un aspect quasi
philosophique au culturel qui a été
lancée pendant je me tourne vers jean
claude lavorel parce que le secteur
chr café hôtellerie restauration est
évidemment l'un des plus frappés par
cette pénurie de main d'oeuvre on en a
parlé la semaine dernière il manque
encore quoi cent cinquante mille
personnes pour l'été c'est ça vous en
êtes à ce constat aussi
aux c'était vraiment la vie beaucoup
plus mais je pense que c'est beaucoup
plus partant contre tous les saisonniers
condo que nous devrions d'avoir bradé
nous personnellement j'ai une douzaine
d'hôtels environ
nous avons élu mot pas loin de 100
personnes ce qui fait quand même
beaucoup parce que ça veut dire que
c'est pas loin de 10 par hôtel et c'est
surtout sur des postes alors on n'est
pas tout à fait en phase avec ce qui a
été dit moi je suis pas tout à fait en
phase avec ce qui a été dit parce que
c'est pendant les les jobs on va dire
les plus simples et plus faciles à
réaliser comme par exemple les fans de
champ on n'a pas de problème les
équipiers les gens qui font le ménage et
les plongeurs ou la moins aucun problème
de recrutement pour ces types de postes
en revanche pour tout ce qui est
restauration et qu'il manque un petit
peu de qualifications alors je parle pas
de la cuisine où ça demande beaucoup de
qualification mais pour le service en
particulier
là au moins on véritablement de une
vraie pénurie le malheur et
je suis d'accord avec ce qui était dit
par rapport à la recherche d'une
meilleure qualité lui au travail c'est
la raison pour laquelle si vous voulez
bien je peux parler de ce que nous avons
réalisé récemment nous a même mis en
place un questionnaire nous avoir
adressé à l'ensemble de nos équipes de
nos salariés avec un certain nombre
d'items pour leur a demandé de classer
les ans classé ces items et et nous
avons repris les principaux items ce qui
arrive est majoritairement en demande de
nos équipes nous demandent nos équipes
il y avait bien évidemment l'argent
ça c'est normal vous drapez simplement
qu'on a eu un ajustement des minima
sociaux mois d'avril qui est quand même
pour nous une augmentation significative
des ja de salaire
on a mis en place donc pour répondre à
leurs attentes nous avons mis en place
un système de d'intéressement c'est à
dire que chaque établissement
chaque salarié touchera un intéressement
au résultat de ces établissements qui
seront ensemble et puis aussi les
cardons jeu je vous interromps mais
peut-être parce qu'on va pas pouvoir
tout déroulée mais il ya aussi et c'est
vraiment intéressant parce que par
essence le métier que vous faites c'est
des métiers où vous vous travaillez
quand faux clients sont tant sont en
vacances ou alors profite le soir etc et
vous allez-vous proposer des primes pour
le tram a et le week-end le soir c'est
c'est donc l'essence même du métier qui
nécessite une prime si je comprends bien
oui parce que c'est revenait également
de questionnaires c'est à dire le point
ramené origen travail le week-end les
problèmes des coupures parce que savait
que dans certains établissements hélas
on ne peut pas faire on n'a pas les
moyens et la quantité de travail
suffisant pour qu'ils continuent donc on
est obligé de faire des coupures en
restauration qui est de ses rails et
s'arrêtent vers 15h15 heure 3 et reprend
vers 18h30 et là on a proposé des
systèmes de primes ajoutez à tout ça on
a également amélioré la qualité de vie
au travail c'est une propose des
massages propose de la réflexologie
plantaire le sérail et tout ça pris sur
le temps de travail mais évidemment je
ne relève pas de leurs de leurs salaires
bas donc ça permet quand même à la fin
du mois pour tous ceux qui qui font des
week-ends qui travaillent les primes
conclure et s'est amélioré de 200 300
euros leur salaire
restez avec nous pendant tout ce débat
évidemment jean claude lavorel mais je
trouve ça vraiment passionnant malaisie
bigi parce que et c'est presque le
modèle enfin le modèle économique de
certains secteurs qui étend alors c'est
vrai aussi avec la transition écologique
évidemment mais qui s'est lié quand on
parle de recherche de sens de la part
des salariés souvent il regarde quel est
le bilan rse responsabilité sociale
sociétale et environnementale des
entreprises en feria tout ça qui se
mélangent en fait est ce que c'est ça
peut aller jusqu'à un changement de
modèle économique parfois pour répondre
à cette demande des salariés ou des
futurs employés est ce que vous diriez
ça alors je vais trop loin si je si je
trancherai cette question mais
simplement de tête rappelé en fait que
aujourd'hui avec ces histoires de
grandes émissions on met l'accent sur
les démissions mais cette quête de
meilleures conditions de travail et de
sens au travail elles et elles datent
d'avant en fait on avait déjà des
enquêtes de 2013 2015 2016 de la barre
est ce qui nous disait que la meilleure
façon de trouver de meilleures
conditions de travail c'était de changer
d'emploi et que un prédicteur en fait de
la démission du changement de métier
c'était la perte de sens donc trouvé son
que ce que son travail ne permet pas de
se réaliser
n'a pas de sens d'utilité sociale voir
voir contrevient à ses valeurs
personnelles et professionnelles donc
après la question qui se pose à mon avis
c'est celle de l'organisation et des
conditions de travail alors est-ce qu'il
faut remettre tout le modèle économique
peut-être mais en tout cas à plus court
terme c'est comme nazi les conditions de
travail et l'organisation du travail un
autre chiffre à vous proposer dans ce
débat sur les les intentions d'embauché
les pompes le pôle emploi par le besoin
en main d'oeuvre plus de 3 millions
+12 % par rapport à 2021 plus de 3
millions c'est sont les chiffres 2022 et
ce qui est intéressant c'est 71% de ses
intentions d'embauché en cdi ou en
contrat de plus de 2 6 mois c'est fanny
milliards est ce que le le cdi ne suffit
plus à séduire un employé aujourd'hui
pour le jeune non en fait c'est plus un
crime mais enfin c'est je caricature
parce que tout le monde mais c'est un
peu la nouveauté c'est à dire que le
jeune diplômé ne qui a des valeurs à
défendre
il ya des jeunes diplômés qui n'ont pas
encore tout le monde n'a pas pas
majoritaire non plus mais celui qui veut
défendre ses valeurs en fait va
considérer que son contrat de travail et
son salaire
sont pas prioritaires par rapport à
l'utilité dans son travail et sa
capacité à apporter
sa pierre à l'édifice un notamment en
matière de respect de l'environnement
n'empêche que pour les les emplois peu
qualifiés
la rémunération reste quand même un
critère essentiel
en particulier dans ce contexte qui est
un cas spécial avec une inflation qui
devient galopante donc lorsque il ya une
ligne enfin il n'ya pas d'adéquation
entre l'offre et la demande est bien
pour réussir à embaucher les personnes
en général augmenter fortement les
salaires ça peut être un critère qui
arrive à convaincre ceux qui bat en
particulier les les emplois peu
qualifiés et benoît sert il faut
augmenter augmenter les salaires c'est
peut-être le préalable mais ça suffit
pas non je pense que ça suffit pas alors
c'est vrai que le contexte d'inflation
il génère beaucoup de débats mais ce
qu'ils avaient vu tout à l'heure c'est à
dire moi je suis plus pas alors la
sphère des salaires c'est une affaire
conjoncturelle d'inflation ça se verra
après mais le vrai sujet et vous
l'évoquez thaler c'est à dire que avant
et voulez vous aller taffer à ça fait
des années qu'on sait que la qualité de
vie au travail et le management par là
où tout ça on sait que c'est sous les
gens veulent je faisais pas il ya pas de
pression maintenant ils n'ont plus le
choix ils reviennent pas mais vous avez
aussi je crois un truc qui monte d'air
qui a été repris par président élu suite
des propositions du medef de
retravailler quand même ce qu'on appelle
le partage de la valeur je pense que ça
c'est très important
dire que les gens le salaire dans lequel
vous rentrez c'est pas lui qui va créer
votre engagement il va vous convaincre
de venir parce que vous avez des
contraintes économiques parce que peu
importe que c'est pas ça qui va vous
faire rester la guerre des salaires ça
ne marche pas à la fin de l'histoire les
gens s'en vont en plus vous avez une
relation au cdi qui est en train de se
distendre un tout petit peu alors c'est
assez limité en france contrairement à
d'autres pays parce que toute la société
est organisée autour du cdi pour avoir
un logement pour l'eau pour emprunter de
l'argent pour lire une voiture tout mon
corps cdi tout d'un coup vous perdez un
certain nombre de choses dans d'autres
pays on parle beaucoup du bic ou aux
états unis mais parce que le marché
travail est beaucoup plus fluide 10/06
profite du tout donc vous avez vous avez
ce phénomène là mais je crois
qu'effectivement les entreprises sais
pas si c'est un changement de modèle
économique mais c'est certainement un
changement du rapport aux salariés et de
l'inclusion du salarié dans l'entreprise
son succès ou pas sont succèdés c'est la
question du partage de la valeur qui va
revenir très fort aujourd'hui à 50% à
peu près des salariés français qui ont
accès à l'intéressement participation
j'ai vu que vous en avez des projets
enfin on va avancer plus mais ne devrait
avoir des projets pour essayer de faire
progresser sa comme monsieur l'a dit
tout à l'heure parce que ça ce sont des
éléments qui crée un lien différent que
celui du lien de subordination ou de
hiérarchie ou de salaire entre
l'entreprise et ses salariés parce que
ça donne du sens à une part de son
travail puisqu'on lui en renvoie une
partie et puis le dernier point là
dessus moi je crois quelque chose que
nous avons tous et je me mets dedans
oublier c'est que les gens sont
extrêmement sensibles à la qualité du
travail qu'ils font ce que je veux dire
par là c'est que s'ils ne comprennent
pas où ils sont dans la chaîne de valeur
si on leur dit en croupe si on leur dit
pas voilà pourquoi ce que vous faites
est essentiel pour celui d'avant et
celui d'après et on a trop travaillé pas
trop ces maladies mais on s'est beaucoup
focalisé sur la qualité de vie au
travail et pas assez sur la qualité du
travail or c'est la qualité du travail
qui génère le plus engagement quand les
gens comprennent ce qu'ils font et c'est
pour ça qu'aujourd'hui on a des
phénomènes on ne trouve pas des gens
dans des métiers qui sont pourtant ni
salle ni du rni mal payés finances c'est
épouvantable 1er âge c ur table
autrement dit le rapport a changé et je
pense que le rapport il vient aussi de
votre rôle est important on vous forme à
ça et on vous reconnaît passe par sa via
le partage de la valeur mais vous avez
raison qu'il faut que la société se
réadapte déjà commencé par les
employeurs ce soit sur le partage de la
valeur ajoutée et quand même été très
défavorable au travail sur les vingt
trente quarante dernières années et sur
ce que vous disiez sur la flexibilité
c'est très important ses atouts il ya
une époque où le medef réclamait
toujours plus de flexibilité et le medef
la fédération française des banques
n'ouvrait pas de contentement pour les
gens en cdd donc il y a il y avait un
hiatus une dissociation de la
personnalité on ne peut pas faire
supporter tout le poids de la
flexibilité aux gros au seul salarié
c'est vrai que ça ça va être une remise
en cause culturelle profonde jean claude
lavorel je reviens vers vous parce
qu'effectivement vous avez mis en place
ce plan d'intéressement des salariés
mais bon vous pouvez vous lui permettre
tout le secteur du ch et enfin de la caf
et café hôtellerie restauration peut pas
se le permettre
c'est là où ce que dit bien dire
monsieur est tout à fait intéressant
c'est à dire que on donne un sens à nos
équipes moi j'ai pour habitude j'ai
toujours communiquer sur les chiffres
d'affaires les objectifs la rentabilité
tout ce qui concerne une entreprise en
réalité je trouve que faire participer
les salariés c'est c'est aussi leur
indiquer pourquoi ils travaillent dans
quelle entreprise est un indicateur
important dans notre métier c'est le
taux de satisfaction de la clientèle et
ça aujourd'hui on sait qu'il est mesuré
mais sur internet donc s'il évolue on
dit bravo aux salariés si limur auront
laissé le comprend pourquoi alors le
fait de les deux leaders suivre de
l'ordre de les informer en permanence du
bûcher d'affaires de la rentabilité
serre permet de comprendre que ben le
gâchis c'est fini bon si on peut éviter
de jeter de métro aux assiettes de rêve
d'avoir un gâchis en général un pas que
sur la consommation alimentaire et à
tous les niveaux l'eau qui coule et
qu'on laisse couler pas je peux vous
prendre 250 exemple et nous chez nous on
a va intéresser depuis un moment pas mal
de temps même où elle est seule
responsable
pour rappel on n' team green team et en
a dans chaque établissement un
responsable de cette team est en
correspondance pour l'épauler différents
hôtels donc c'est c'est un suivi ses
global c'est-à-dire qu'on s'intéresse
aussi bien aux économies d'énergie qui
vont générer un indubitablement aussi à
terme un peu de profit au moins de
pertes mais comme ça on arrive à des
résultats qui sont très satisfaisants ne
pas vous donner ici n'est pas le propos
nos résultats mais je pense que pas
pendant au secteur en général on a un
taux de satisfaction de nos clients est
élevé et une rentabilité était très
molle et ça et ça et ça mais quand j'en
parle d' intéressement et je le redis je
souhaite partager mois le résultat de
leurs établissements entre eux tous ils
sont 106 65 ans dont on partagera une
grosse partie de ce résultat parce que
on partage pas tout vu qu'il faut quand
même garder du cash pour les travaux
d'entretien de l'établissement et son
amélioration mais une grosse partie ça
ils ont ça donne un sens où on est ça
pour qui travaille ça pourquoi il prêt
et il suit une aubry si ce genre lorelei
qui vendent ou interrompre jean claude
lavorel pour pour parler vous l'avez
évoqué la question des jeunes
diplômé de l'université ou des grandes
écoles certains refusent le destin tout
tracé alors il ya une séquence qui avait
marqué évidemment elle date c'était pas
si longtemps c'est le 30 avril dernier
ces ingénieurs agronomes d'agroparistech
qui prennent la parole lors de la remise
des diplômes regardez nous ne voyons pas
les sciences et techniques comme neutre
et apolitique
nous pensons que l'innovation
technologique ou les start up ne
sauveront rien d'autre que le
capitalisme nous ne croyons ni au
développement durable ni à la croissance
verte ni à la transition écologique une
expression qui sous-entend que la
société pourra devenir soutenable sans
qu'on se débarrasse de l'ordre social
dominant pondre des rapports rse
d'autant plus long et délirant que les
crimes qu'il masque sont scandaleux ou
encore compter des grenouilles et des
papillons pour que les bétonneurs puisse
les faire disparaître légalement ces
jobs sont destructeurs et les choisir
c'est nuire en servant les intérêts de
quelques-uns c'est pourtant ses
débouchés qui nous ont été présentés
tout au long de notre cursus
agroparistech en revanche on ne nous a
jamais parlé de des diplômés qui
considère que ces métiers font davantage
partie des problèmes que des solutions
et qui ont choisi de déserter alors
depuis on a vu des séquences peut-être
moins radicale mais un peu similaire à
polytechnique ou hec
malaisie bij et comment vous interpréter
ses prises de parole est ce que c'est
même presque la valeur travail qui est
un peu remise en cause une certaine
façon alors moi je trouve ça tout à fait
réjouissant de les réentendre
aujourd'hui et je sais pas si c'est la
valeur travail si je pense que sa fin ce
qu'ils racontent démontre un très fort
attachement
la valeur travail simplement peut-être
qu'ils veulent ne veulent plus consentir
un travail qui pour eux n'a pas de sens
qui est potentiellement exercer dans de
pas très bonnes conditions pour des
brèmes une ration pas très élevé bons
skis probablement pas alors ke diplômés
d'agroparistech mais on peut leur
rétorquer que pour faire évoluer ces
entreprises il faut y entrer c'est l'un
des reproches à l'intérieur changer de
l'intérieur ou à rester à l'extérieur
mais mais bon je pense que ça interroge
c'est qu'au delà de la valeur travail
l'interrogation qui est porté par ses
jeunes je pense que ça nous redit en
fait que pour eux le travail c'est
construire une société que nous
apprécions avec des valeurs qu'on compte
chéri qu'on souhaite c'est participer à
la construction sociale en fait puisque
travail au coeur de l'activité sociale
est en fait eux se rendent compte que
les boulot qu'on leur propose ou oqali
sont plutôt destinées vont pas dans ce
sens là d'après eux et donc ils veulent
plus consentir à ça mais est-ce que
benoît ça c'est une remise en cause de
peut-être de l'ags la grande entreprise
parce que c'est un peu ça aussi ils ont
été faire des choix si on rentre un peu
dans le détail ans n'a pas pu mais toute
la séquence mais de micro-entreprises de
structure beaucoup plus coopérative et c
est ce que c'est pas un rejet de du
cac40 quoi oui je schématise
involontairement oui j'ai eu la chance
de les rencontrer en fait après vous
discuté c'était intéressant donc je
pense qu'il ya une part de ça tousse on
sait pas nouveau que les les grandes
entreprises sont moins attractives on a
l'impression que c'est des machines
résine humaine donc ça a été un travail
à faire là dessus après moi j'ai bien
écouté puis ça a été repris dans
d'autres écoles depuis espèce de
phénomène de buzz là kiki partie c'était
intéressant les écoutait ce qui me gêne
un peu ce que je leur ai dit c'est qu'en
fait c'est une logique de tribune
politique alors que moi je parle
d'entreprises je parle d'emploi et je
parle d'arrêter sociale c'est un peu là
défaut du système moi je rien qu'on
dirait au contraire chacun chacun est
libre d'exprimer mais du coup c'est la
nuit un peu
donc sa nuit un petit peu à la portée du
message en ai vu plein d'autres des gens
parce qu'évidemment de notre entreprise
aussi gens sont très sensibles à ça il
viens nous en parler il vous demande
vous faites quoi quel engagement vous
prenez etc donc ça c'est très important
mais en étant dans le système à nous
d'apprendre qu'on recrute un jeune
souvent il nous dit mais en fait je suis
trop bas dans la hiérarchie pour que
vous mais coutier sur ces sujets là donc
ça c'est un vrai travail de l'entreprise
d'aller chercher et de dire c'est pas
parce qu'ils sont jeunes diplômés qui
viennent d'arriver et c'est que ils ont
ils sont là pour exécuter et pas pour
donner donc ça c'est des structures et
de l'organisation renonce à l'idée même
des plus à ça et dans les jeux en europe
idate dont discours était assez fort à
la fin de l'histoire si vous n'avez pas
du tout ce que c'est assez long en fait
ils sortent du jeu wii est juste pas sûr
qu'on change le jeu en étant à
l'extérieur en étant à l'extérieur c'est
un peu ce que est en cours moi je pense
en revanche que les entreprises ont une
responsabilité d'intégrer ce genre de
phénomène pour dire changer vos modèles
écraser vos hiérarchie faites attention
parce que sinon vous allez développer
tout un tas de comportement de gens qui
disent mais non les prêts à vous aider
on est prêt à ce que vous prenez plus
fortement conscience que vous prenez
mais sauf que vous écoutez pas parce que
vous êtes un modèle hiérarchie et pour
finir sur les grandes entreprises on est
pour une minute je vous promets c'est
que elles sont très organisés de manière
pyramidale or moi quand je rencontre ces
jeunes notamment dans la tête mais pas
que ils sont pas intéressés par les
carrières pyramidale ils sont intéressés
par changer le projet de manière
régulière et ça pour nos entreprises
c'est une sacrée question parce que
comme on évoquait une évolution du
modèle de relation avec le salarié d'un
par rapport au bénéfice d'entreprises ou
des prestations de ces résultats il faut
aussi qu'on arrive à travailler sur les
modèles d'organisation beaucoup plus
écrasés parce que la pyramide ne fait
plus rêver et je vais vous donner un
chiffre une enquête qui a été menée par
la drh et le bcg ya deux ans on avait
interrogé d'enfants
on avait interrogé en europe 4000 jeunes
non manager en leur demandant qui
voudrait devenir manager 15 % ont
répondu je veux devenir manager vous
avez 85% et nos managers sait sur quel
pays d'europe dont la france qui disent
moi ça m'intéresse pas de monter dans la
pyramide ça c'est vraiment interrogeant
sur les organisations d'entreprises
voient parfois la pression qu amy sur
les cadres intermédiaires donnent plus
indirect si la voix sait que le bois
existe et
stéphanie bière c'est un mouvement de
fond ça ça rejoint parce que c'est si on
en parle dans ce débat c'est qu'on
finalement on se pose la question du
sens du travail des raisons pour
lesquelles les salariés sont en train de
démissionner pour certains ou entre deux
jobs pour d'autres c'est la même logique
et à l'heure est ce que vous direz que
c'est un mouvement de foule ah oui c'est
une véritable lame de fond et moi je
pense qu'au contraire ça remet le notre
modèle néolibéral
en question parce que derrière en fait
c'est la consommation de masse qui remis
en cause par par ces jeunes ils vont
vers une consommation plus responsable
plus local
moins polluantes et ce dans l'eure dans
leurs discours ils se disent que
produire en polluant pour permettre une
partie infime de la population de
s'enrichir alors que les dégâts
environnementaux veille de payer
collectivement ça le modèle ne peut plus
fonctionner on allait dans une planète
de 2 - ample - habitable donc les jeunes
c'est quand même le pouvoir de demain si
à ce jeu je pense qu'il y aura pas de
retour en arrière et qui va bien falloir
pour les grands groupes et les petits
groupes de s'emparer de la problématique
des jeunes parce qu'une entreprise
elle a pour vocation de vendre ses
produits de faire du chiffre d'affaires
et vous ne se produit si derrière et
bien ceux qui achètent en général ce
sont eux qui ont ce sont les plus jeunes
assis à ce blocage ou à la dépense pour
ce type de produit bas la salle a posé
un problème et une remise en cause des
petits et des plus grands groupes alors
vous connaissez le dicton l'herbe n'est
pas forcément plus verte ailleurs elle
devrait aussi en matière d'emploi je
propose un style jourdain ii de nous
rejoindre
bonsoir si vous êtes intéressé a assez
française et ces français qui ont
démissionné et qu'il regrette oui c'est
une enquête qui a été menée entre
décembre 2021 et janvier 2022 sur près
de 2000 employés qui ont rendu leur
tablier enquête réalisée par la société
morning console tu regardais ce chiffre
éloquent 63% 63% des français qui ont
quitté leur travail pendant la pandémie
affirme avoir démissionné trop
rapidement il regrette d'avoir quitté
leur job alors même distille que cette
décision a été très difficile à prendre
a noté thomas que l' enquête a été menée
dans plusieurs pays en allemagne aux
pays bas aux états unis et c'est bien en
france que ce chiffre est le plus élevé
les français démissionnaires sont
mélancoliques d'autant plus que
seulement un tiers d'entre eux ont
retrouvé du travail après leur démission
ce qui est intéressant aussi bien c'est
de constater qu'en france on est
champion de la démotivation selon cette
même enquête quand on demande aux
français pourquoi ils ont démissionné
bien la réponse qui revient le plus
souvent c'est le manque de valorisation
le mauvais management de leur patron un
argument qui est très spécifique à nous
français est ce que les patrons français
sont eux aussi mélancolique oui les
chefs regrettent leur ancien salarié
selon cette enquête près de trois quarts
des managers française serait enclin à
réembaucher ceux qui sont partis pendant
la pandémie une donnée qu'il faut quand
même un peu nuancer un toujours sept
selon cette même enquête seulement un
patron sur cinq se dit prêt à
réembaucher tous les salariés qui sont
partis puis je termine avec ce chiffre
il est intéressant on est les champions
la double démission thomas puisque parmi
les français qui ont démissionné depuis
le début de la pandémie près de la
moitié d'entre eux ont démissionné une
deuxième fois c'est à dire eh bien
qu'ils ont retrouvé un poste puis ont à
nouveau jeté l'épongé dans la foulée 49%
c'est quand même deux fois le taux des
autres pays européens encore une
exception française merci beaucoup steve
pour tous ces informations quand on
discute stephenie meyer avec des des
patrons de sociétés d'intérim
ils décrivent des
des chercheurs d'emploi qui sont passés
maîtres dans l'art de jongler avec
leurs droits au chômage et reese accepte
plusieurs missions il cumule
suffisamment d'heures y retourne à pôle
emploi pendant trois ou quatre mois
est-ce qu'il ya pas aussi un peu de ça
dans le phénomène qu'on est en train de
vie sert des français qui voient là on a
un système qui existe les protecteurs
c'est très bien et qui vont à rouen
appris à en jouer le plus possible
je ne sais pas si en france on en joue
plus plus qu'ailleurs effectivement bas
aussi l'intérim sait aussi s'adapter à
des contrats plus courts voire très
court alors est ce que il profite de ça
où ils subissent a enfin il ya la
question années a besoin d'être d'être
clairement posée sous lorsqu'on demande
à ses à ses salariés est ce que vous
préféreriez avoir un emploi fixe style
cdi la grande majorité disent oui donc
l'intérim ça reste quand même un emploi
précaire avec une pour la grande
majorité d'entre eux un espoir de
retrouver un emploi type cdi c'est par
définition difficile à évaluer mesic b j
mais est ce que le jeu
c'est le lien est ce que le travail au
noir est en progression en france
j'essaie de trouver des explications au
phénomène qu'on décrit depuis le début
de ce débat alors là vous me posez
vraiment et oui je sais bien par
définition il est très difficile à
évaluer quoi vous pouvez vraiment une
colle mais mais pour rebondir sur ce que
vous disiez en fait les secteurs qui
sont enfin le plus travaillé dans
l'intérim c'est aussi des secteurs où il
ya les moins bonnes conditions de
travail ou les atteintes à la santé sont
les plus fortes et du coup l'onglet
entre des périodes d'activité de nos
activités c'est aussi en fait fait pour
préserver sa santé est conservé à
reproduire la force de travail on fait
donc on peut aussi voir ces périodes de
travail et non travaillé sous l'angle de
la santé tout comme en fait il ya des
emplois qui sont difficilement
soutenable même en cdi parce qu'ils sont
trop difficiles en fait à tenir benoît
c'est à vous parler de ghosting de
refesse de candidats entre guillemets
fantôme
c'est un phénomène qui existe est jamais
qu et qui s'est beaucoup amplifié on le
constate que j'ai parlé avec mes
confrères et consoeurs l'un des rages
c'est tout le monde le constate c'est le
fait que vous rencontrez un candidat une
fois deux fois trois fois voulu faire
des propositions
vous avez plus de nouvelles il disparaît
ils vous répondent jamais finale alors
que vous l'ayez fait une proposition
vous l'avez vu trois fois et ça c'est un
phénomène qui est pour le coup est en
train de monter extrêmement fort les
entreprises où beaucoup de gens sont
assez désemparé un plus rapidement ils
ont ils en déduisent que ce sont pas des
gens sérieux mais je pense que c'est un
vrai sujet pour vous faire sourire bien
des rachats qu'ils discutaient qui
disent en étant totalement outre et donc
je vais juste demandé s'il avait répondu
à tous les cv qu'il avait reçues depuis
une vingtaine d'années et donc c'était
une forme de juste retour des choses par
contre sur les sécurités donné par votre
confrère tout à l'heure c'est
intéressant de de constater que ça c'est
d'une traduction du rapport au travail
ces chiffres là mais clairement et ça
qui est intéressant c'est que il ya le
jeu est en train de changer personne
c'est très bien quand il va s'établir il
est hyper instable et c'est d'ailleurs
pour ça que beaucoup d'entreprises sont
en train de mettre en place deux choses
une chose qui existait déjà et la
cooptation c'est à dire qu'ils passent
par leur équipe pour faire venir des
gens pour créer un lien différent de
celui de vie habituel et la deuxième
chose si vous avez beaucoup d'autres
possibles commencent à mettre en place
des systèmes de boomerang c'est à dire
qu'ils vont rechercher des gens qui ont
démissionné en leur disant ok tu t'es
louper c'est dommage ou faire partie on
propose revenus pas forcément des
augmentations de salaire à la clé et ça
ça marche plutôt ça marche plutôt pas
mal et puis je pense qu'il ya aussi un
autre chiffre qui a été donnée qui est
que la france est quand même très élevé
en terme de jeu regrette d'être parti
c'est ce que j'évoquais tout à l'heure
c'est parce que vous vous rendez compte
que quand vous sortez du marché légal
contractuels du travail vous payer la
facture directe sur tout un tas de
sujets on l'évoquait thaler votre
logement vous n'êtes pas notre jeu quand
vous allez problème pour est un sujet ça
je pense que d'eux mêmes que pour la
participation intéressement je pense que
ça c'est un sujet dans les pouvoirs lui
devrait se saisir parce que ça ça bloque
le marché du travail plus que sun le
protège
dernier thème il nous reste un peu moins
de cinq minutes cette pénurie de main
d'oeuvre at elle changé le regard de la
société française sur l'immigration
écouter ce que disait le président du
medef sur l'immigration économique
c'était le 1er juin dernier sur france
info sur le long terme les pays
européens dont la france vont devoir
réfléchir sérieusement à l'immigration
économique on est une population
vieillissante
c'est comme ça la france d'ailleurs un
peu moins que les autres on a un système
de protection sociale qui repose sur le
travail c'est les cotisations de ceux
qui travaillent qui payent les
prestations sont notamment les retraites
et donc si on a de moins en moins de
deux groupes de jeunes qui travaillent
c'est juste mathématiques moi ma
conviction profonde c'est que pour
résoudre les problèmes d'intégration qui
existe et qu'on peut pas nier le travail
c'est la meilleure solution jean claude
lavorel l'umih l'union des métiers de
l'hôtellerie vient de signer choix que
tu es le 30 juin le principe d'un
recrutement de saisonniers avec la la
tunisie alors je l'impression que ça
intervient un peu trop tard pour pour
cet été mais sur le principe c'est une
piste quoi vous dites quoi évidente à
creuser n'y a pas d'autre solution
oui moi de ce que j'en sais ce qui m'a
été dit c'est que cette piste elle est
elle elle va être mise en place pour
2023 et l'ampera pour 2022 je crois que
les accords qui ont été signés avec le
gouvernement puis c'est pour l'an
prochain
pour revenir sur ce qui était évoqué par
par le président du medef en réalité
nous ont fait appel déjà et main
d'oeuvre parfois polonaise roumaine et
ça ne nous pose pas de problème on
essaye d'avoir les des traducteurs quand
il le faut enfin jouer si vous le
permettez revenir sur ce qui a été dit
en matière de management une des grandes
problématiques en même que leur
augmenteront
bien évidemment il ya le dirigeant de
dirigeants il fait pas tout dans une
autre président ben je sais que je
communique beaucoup je suis au milieu de
mes équipes normand il ya des managers
intermédiaires maintenant notre métier
c'est directeur de tel directoire la
restauration etc et c'est là où le il ya
sûrement un manque de formation parce
qu'on a encore et nous c'est notre
faiblesse si on s'en rend compte et on
essaie de les améliorer des managers à
l'ancienne c'est à dire que mais il faut
pas participer les équipes y sont ils
communient peu ils sont dans un système
surtout dans la terrier la restauration
et en particulier restauration qui est
un peu vieillissant et qui sont les
méthodes diarra 30 ans donc
je pense qu'il ya beaucoup de travail à
faire pour les écoles etc pour le
management intermédiaire que le manager
de l'entreprise décide pas tout il est
pas tout temps présent au milieu de ses
équipes c'est eux qui à pulse équipe
comme inique ce que nous mettons en
place enfin je voudrais revenir sur le
parena la bonne solution puisque nous
nous mêmes nous aimons bien ça en place
il ya environ 3 4 ans chaque salarié qui
nous prennent une de ses connaissances
ou dans son réseau peu importe doit
recevoir au bout de six mois il faut que
celui qui la parraine et reste au moins
six mois s'il reste très peu c'est pas
ça vaut pas un problème oui six mois ils
touchent une prime qui est quand même
significative et qui
leur plaît beaucoup voila voila merci
j'ai dit merci merci je vous interromps
pardon c'est la fin de l'émission merci
d'y avoir participé merci à vous
également d'avoir participé à ce débat
très bientôt sur sur public sénat